hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series to try to learn from
people who've done a lot more than us
hang around them just a little bit
longer and hopefully some of their
mindsets beliefs attitude work ethic
seeps into our brain that helps us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn from Conor
McGregor on being motivated mentor me
Conor and as always if Connor says
something that really really resonates
with you please write it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy you want to beat the king right
the current king the current king you're
looking at the current king Arya you're
interviewing the current king and the
current king is here July 10th the
current king will be there 145 pounds
July 11 the current king will be there
raising gold so I don't care it's the
McGregor show let's be honest it would
be great to have it with all the work
they put in but I cannot force an
individual if they are afraid if an
individual is afraid to fight you cannot
force him so it is what it is if he's
running if he's scared there's nothing I
can do I'd probably if I sometimes I
look in the mirror and get little
flights as well looking at myself
because I am an absolute animal a
machine so I probably wouldn't want to
find me either
so it is what it is I'll be there I know
that they say I'm just talk but here I
am walking where's where's everybody
else
I'm here I own this town I only occasion
arrow
so by him to say he is a king and I am
the Joker and this was a different time
I would invade this favela on horseback
and kill anyone that was not fit to walk
we are in a new time so our bombers are
in July obviously you need you to make
history by fighting Papillon to San Jose
that didn't happen and now you fight
Eddie its Eddie an easier route Easter I
think that's something your coach I'm
having like that I think they're very
SIL I think they're all the same to all
you know even look at the contenders I
fought last week like they're not I
thought I almost feel like upset that I
even been mentioned in it Peter I take
that is everyone although not all like
they're all way way down like this I
look at these fights and I realize boy
the game has never broke into that next
level before because nobody's at that
next level I'm the only one of that next
level so I look forward to going out
shown what I know that these people do
not stand a chance
is a huge accomplishment tonight was
there anything at all surprising about
it to you not one be the norm I never
you gotta have sighs yeah Liege lengths
you've gotta have some attributes if you
come in anyway equal to me I'm gonna rip
your whole head off and that's it every
time
Eddie's a solid
Eddie's a one
we shouldn't be in here with me you know
hard work pays I put in a hell of a walk
all true oh this buildup in the fire I
point out more content than anybody more
content than Fox more content than ESPN
more content than BT sport more content
and everybody on the Mac live on my own
channels you know me and I mu course
from all angles not just in the gym but
I'm building this media empire now
myself we pumped out the content I'm
very proud of the hell went we
consistently daily movies I was
releasing you know from from like a
month ago every single day you know I
mean nobody's doing that so I'm very
proud of that and I'm very like the work
pays hard work pays and we put I put in
the [ __ ] morgue and that's that's why
I'm I'm sitting at the top I put it all
on the line I show up I perform and I
get the results from that so what's
working in the plumbing business I was
working in the plumbing business I have
to tie me about and I'm telling it was
it would have been around that time that
John and lastly I had left the phone
business I left the flooring business
how bad was that diploma yeah horrendous
what were you actually in the trenches I
mean it was in industrial so I'll be
like building this it'd be like diploma
that would be needed in a place like
this six o'clock in the morning and the
motorway and I just have to walk for
about an hour to get there to get there
on motorway then I stand on the edge of
the motorway and wait for a bloke to
drive boy so give me a lift and then the
motorway was like getting them
renovation at the time so take me two or
two hours to get to the place was out in
the country gonna be there for 10 hours
walking and I was a first year so as the
worst of the war sermons on the
beginning then two hours to get back in
the traffic again was just a horrible
horrible time and I was like you know
what I don't want to deal with this and
then I just left and then I just stopped
on didn't get out of bed let me die with
me to try and Bank me out of bed we have
fights and militia for a good world I
never spoke I didn't really speak to
Medina who just kind of stayed away from
each other anytime I any time I come
across me guy just icon we did speak was
foot was the fight he lived in his house
yeah little Tony anything assembly
anything you didn't talk to him isn't
that it kinda awkward not like it wasn't
my dad
you have just a deep relation yeah not
yeah numbers but since this since this
is happy right since the dream has
happened since the vision that I had has
come true and like he went to he went
through two thumbs over because he got
testicular cancer so he got sick and all
over and there in my head of thinking
maybe maybe I don't that because he's
worried about me and there's not what
I'm gonna do on all these fights that
were having all the time but I'm talking
full-on fight you come in and punch it
but no not it yeah we'll go around
you're punching back but yeah we were
going out of here wow what does your mom
say about that it was so protective of
you
yeah I'm in Raleigh she's with her I
don't know it was just she just stayed
out in our book and butts easy to get to
that point toward he was despot in I was
doing absolutely nothing I said well in
the trouble yeah basically felt like I
was doing football I was a waster yeah I
was a waster got that call that a lot
and I remember but now like Ellen and
then wonder when I start getting that
focus and realize enough I'm gonna I'm
gonna make this happen and then never
has happened I'm um I'm making it happen
I'm a great relationship with that like
we talk all the time and I even see
energy and I see energy and you might
like it's the present times for a lot of
people around there's a lot of bad stuff
going on in the country a lot of people
are struggling everybody's struggling
but now since since the MT me chase this
dream it's given them an energy and I
see a new lease of life in them and that
alone spores me on even more so it's all
just a perfect storm that's happening
for me and that is why I have this
tunnel vision and that's why I'm willing
to kill every single man in my path to
get that built environment is to secure
the future from my family's future you
know I mean that's that's what I'm doing
for when I was a kid he's always
visualized Stadium something and like
even when I was playing football I'd
kick the ball against the wall and I'd
pretend that I scored a goal and I'd
rule
and I'd be raising my hand and
visualizing a arena full of fans another
stop some I don't as a kid I'm out on my
own I like just running around kicking
the ball I always had these visions of
something but I just didn't know what it
was and then I suppose when I came to
this of these events I know it stopped
raining in me I think came to an event I
was like okay this is it this is this is
what I'm gonna do and then now I'm doing
keep seeking more you keep you know they
tell me tell me you'll never do this
you'll never win win world tales
I've done it consecutively so we keep
pushing the pushing the envelope keep
keep going so I'm almost I conquer one
and then I'm on to the next so I I walk
and I hustle like like I'm not in the
position I'm in here I mean like I said
I'm say like at least she just put my
feel but I hosted like I'm not in that
position I walk like I'm not in that
position you stare at your past and
you'll end up staying there it's okay to
look back and admire it
but you carry on I'm not I'm not I'm not
in the business of staring staring back
at it you know I mean I'm getting lost
back there it's people say you can
people say a loss can make a break a
fighter but trust me a win can also make
a break a fire because they get
comfortable with it with a win people
can get comfortable with it with a win
and and and slack off then slack off on
the Train and slack off on the diet
they've won one they're winners now
that's not me you know you sleep on a
you sleep on a win and you'll wake up
with a loss so I just carry on keep
doing what I'm doing and that's why
these turnaround is so good for me they
get straightaway the Fighting Irish head
to the fighting capital it's it's
perfect continue on this path the
freight train straight to the top for me
I love this I look proving people wrong
I'm proving my support right that's what
it's about at the end of the day you
know this is this is all fun and games
to me I love it
I love my job I would people for
truckloads of cash
how could I hate this life I love it so
much I am grateful every single day as
you ever have
let's call it a normal job Connor a
nine-to-five yeah because the oldest
thing is the games were trade straight
away I was no different
soon as I finished skill I was always
getting pestered what are you doing with
your life you known this day on that and
they didn't know what it was they didn't
know if MMA wasn't known I just didn't
know it could make a career as far as
they were consent me mind that I'm
talking about as far as they were
concerned I'm just getting into a cage
and fighting some other guy they didn't
know nothing about it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew where there and then I got end up
getting a trade just to keep them quiet
zhuzi it had a lot of fights with me
dialogue like trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber and
literally open the back eyes and I were
up and we clock the Wicklow Mountains
and Faline about that but sight was one
of the biggest sites in Europe kill
Tiernan was right at that ski in place
huge and now it's just abandoned now
it's just deserted so I used to go up
there 6 o'clock 5 spoken Amano's on that
m50 I just had to walk to the end for
about half an hour from your hair was
way for some memory card I didn't even
know he drove on the m4 and had to flag
him down nightmare yeah two hours down
on the m50 two hours back literally
14-hour days and obviously I was the
first year I was the I had to go and do
everything like to go to the shop I'd to
go and get this and get that so I always
had trouble down I was like this isn't
for me this is not for me
how long did you last I lasted 18 18
months stealing what was talking on it
just so it wasn't wasn't alive for me
and I'd and then John said because I was
training with jhana as well at the time
and then John got on tour chances there
I have a show on the show would like to
fight honey and then that was he I just
packed it in didn't show up weed I used
to come in and punch the head on me and
like try and drag me out of bed and I
just wouldn't go and I'm it hadn't opal
or for a good few years when I'm over
Abel and and that was there I just
packed it in quit and then focused on
training and that's I knew I knew I knew
what was gonna happen I knew I was going
to get here
they didn't there's a lot of stressful
years you know a lot of tough times and
but I proved them wrong I proved myself
right gonna be out on all the Irish
people my understand more hey young a
young
like dreaming a point on the artist
jersey or dreaming I'm pulling on his
favorite football team's Jersey and that
cryst and lifting that coupe you know
this this is my crest these gloves right
here it is UFC close enough be the force
mark large man to put these on to lace
these upper and get in and do the job
honestly long can take that await me now
what uncle
honestly I don't mean to be
disrespectful I don't care about
anything else I don't know about Nelson
I don't even listen to advice to talk
about something else just don't listen
don't just I'm talking [ __ ] but if I
talk about this if I talk about unarmed
combat if I talk about the human anatomy
yeah I mean the way the human body Mills
then listen I think it's important that
you put a conscious at
conscious effort into appreciating your
surroundings and I mean that's what I do
with this place I absolutely love this
city and even you know what I was
thinking a lot about normal Park Theatre
yesterday after that thing happened
where he was saying about Northern
Ireland then they did it's a disgrace
and it's this and it's that's it's a
negative thing towards your home nation
or whatever you know boom that's not the
right way to be you need to have a
commune oh you need to appreciate your
surroundings and be grateful for and
that's when good things happen a lot of
bitterness and that negativity then then
things are gone bad I mean so I think
the fact that I had them talks now fact
I appreciate everything and I'm grateful
for for the things around me and that
the way things are going that's why
that's why it's going so good for me
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think this video did it mean
something to you did you like it what
was your favorite clip leave it down the
comments below also did you get
motivated by it or what do you do to be
motivated in your business really
curious to find out leave in the
comments I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon